hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll so
how about those viruses so hot right now
right everyone's talking about viruses
you know why we're in the midst of a
quarantine global pandemic with the
novel coronavirus leading to the Cova
Denine teen disease but he heard
mindscape were less about the concerns
at the moment and more about the
big-picture issues that are gonna last
for a very long time so let's talk not
about this particular pandemic but about
the idea of viruses more generally and
there's probably no more expert person
to talk to than today's guest David
Baltimore who won the Nobel Prize in
Physiology and medicine for virus
related activity back in the 1970s he
has collaborators were the ones who
showed something called reverse
transcription you might know that in
genetics in cellular biology there's
something called the central dogma that
says that DNA stores information RNA
goes over the DNA and gets assembled in
a way that can pick up that information
and then the RNA carries it over to be
converted into proteins that's the
central dogma the DNA stores the RNA
carries and then proteins are
constructed so reverse transcription as
discovered by Baltimore and others shows
how RNA can actually go and affect
the DNA in fact it turns out that in
viruses unlike in every other kind of
information carrying organism I don't
want to say living organism because
there's a debate about whether viruses
are alive or not but let's just say that
the back and forth between DNA and RNA
and proteins is extremely rich inside
viruses and as Baltimore went on to show
this has important implications for
things like how viruses can cause cancer
specific kinds of viruses like the HIV
virus and indeed right now when you talk
about different kinds of viruses
you'll probably refer to the Baltimore
classification of viruses which is named
after David not after the city of
Baltimore so for most of this episode we
talk about what viruses are are they
really alive how do they interact with
organisms with genomes how do they hop
from one kind of organism to another but
then we do at the end to get a little
bit more specific about the current
a virus and also about some bigger
picture questions about gene editing
about the origin of consciousness and I
asked it a little bit about what he
thinks about how corona virus has
impacted us and how we should be
responding to it let me just say that he
has strong words for how we've been
responding to it and how we could do
better not necessarily about you know
social distancing anything like that but
how the public health infrastructure
should be ready for things like this in
this day and age this should not be
taking us by surprise
so this is one of those episodes of
mindscape which is both very interesting
but also very important two things going
on right now that's a rare thing that's
usually not what we do around here but I
think it works in this case
so let's go
[Music]
David Baltimore welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so I really want to
talk about viruses as a concept right I
mean this is part of what I try to do
here mindscape is to really dig into
some of the details but we'd be remiss
to not mention the elephant in the room
we're having this conversation during a
kind of quarantine for a pandemic
because of a virus I mean why don't we
let the audience's appetite by putting
the this novel coronavirus into context
like is this virus that we're fighting
against right now is it typical is it
surprising it's the kind of thing that
we should expect going forward well I
think each virus is its own set of
surprises
viruses really only have in common that
they're not cells they can't make their
own proteins they can't make their own
energy so they have to be inside a cell
in order to reproduce themselves but
that's a pretty minimal requirement and
so there are lots and lots of ways that
that requirement is met and and lots and
lots of different kinds of viruses the
present virus that we're seeing we've
never seen on this scale before and we
hadn't done a whole lot of work on the
class of viruses previously we the
scientific community so it a lot of it's
coming as a surprise to us yeah but the
fact that a virus can be this surprising
is itself not surprising I got that
impression in my very brief reading up
on viruses before this conversation oh
my goodness what a mess like viruses are
just much messier than the entire rest
of life or even you know but what we
know is life iris we're not even sure
whether we should call it life well I've
always been comfortable calling viruses
life because they evolved they they do
everything that living systems do the
only thing is they have to be inside a
cell to reproduce maybe that's worth
getting straight for people who are
complete beginners here probably
nobody is at this stage of the
quarantine but I think a lot of people
don't even know the difference is
between virus and a bacteria there's
little germs that make us sick right
I've certainly seen that a lot of people
don't know the difference and bacteria
are cells that are completely
self-sufficient so if you give them
nutrients like you put them on a piece
of fruit or another source of energy
they can absorb that energy and grow
multiply become many skill ian's of
bacteria and a virus can't do that a
virus has to get inside a cell it could
be a bacterial cell so there are
bacterial viruses but the ones that we
care most about our our viruses that
affect humans and they affect humans by
getting inside human cells skin cells
gut cells lung cells all the various
kinds of cells in the body many of them
support viruses right and so one of the
ways in which viruses are not like other
parts of life there's no cell wall right
I mean it's there's no inside and
outside to a virus well there is an
inside and an outside outside it's got a
sort of rigid shell of some kind not
always very rigid and inside it has
genetic material right which is its
secret the code to make more virus and
that has to be liberated from the shell
and get inside the cell and act like the
cells information but basically supplant
the cells information so that the cell
now becomes a virus producing Factory
so it's safe to say that viruses are
parasitic on cellular life yes
fire
is our parasitic on cellular life is
there then some sense in which viruses
could not have come first they needed
cells around already to come into
existence well if they were the kinds of
viruses we see today then that would
certainly be true but we can imagine
that there were other kinds of life
forms that might have degenerated into
viruses but have been in an earlier
stage of evolution more self-sufficient
so there's a whole black box problem
here in what situation did viruses
evolve and it's very hard to know the
answer to that I presume we can't look
at fossils of ancient viruses that's
right we can't or we haven't we haven't
been able to I mean for life we have
this idea that we can find features of a
last Universal common ancestor because
all cellular life has certain genetic
features in common but my impression is
that's not true for viruses viruses
sometimes just kind of spring up without
having a common origin no all viruses
have as their genetic material DNA or
RNA and so they are connected to the
rest of the living world at a very
fundamental level we use the same
genetic code viruses use the same
genetic code as as humans or any other
species does and they are different than
humans or or or plants but they are not
out of the blue okay
so there might be a last Universal
common virus ancestor but I don't think
all viruses evolved from a universal
precursor
I think that there have been multiple
evolutions of viruses that don't have a
common ancestor and I
say it that way because we don't
actually know the answer but the DNA
viruses and the RNA viruses are really
very different from one another the
bacterial viruses particularly the
viruses that grow in marine bacteria or
marine organisms are a very different
set of critters than the ones that cause
human disease for instance and the
plants some of the plant viruses are
very different than most animal viruses
so there are some common ancestors but I
suspect there are some really quite
disparate evolutionary stories okay
okay that don't have a common I don't
have a common base I mean you mentioned
what I think is the most fascinating
fact about the virus is that unlike
cellular life which basically you're the
biologist here correct me if I'm wrong
my impression is that all cellular life
contains its genetic information in a
double strand of DNA and it uses RNA to
make proteins that's the central dogma
of biology but viruses are much more
haphazard like some of them use DNA some
RNA single strands double strands what
have you well I wouldn't call it
haphazard I would call it inventive
mmm-hmm they're not viruses have managed
to use genetic information in ways that
higher cells don't I mean I guess the
usual thing that I'm told is that RNA is
a little bit more fragile than DNA and
therefore DNA makes a better repository
for genetic information do viruses
manage to overcome that obstacle they
they overcome it largely by numbers so
when you get a somebody's infected and
they make new viruses they're making
literally billions of new viruses so the
fact that the if they have an RNA genome
that it is more chemically fragile and
it is
is overcome by numbers I think okay and
and it's not a not a big problem
so if a few of irises don't survive or
don't reproduce accurately we'll just
make more that's that's the philosophy
yeah that's right that's right
and do we think that the I mean there's
a lot of viruses out there and this is
one of the things I read the the number
of different kinds of viruses could be
an order of magnitude larger than the
number of kinds of species of all other
life-forms on earth and every organism
contained many many individual virus
particles so how do we even start to
sort of impose order on all of this
variety let's sort of classify what
kinds of different viruses there are
well virologists have enjoyed themselves
by going into the natural world
isolating viruses and then
characterizing them in the electron
microscope to get an idea what their
structure is chemically to get an idea
of their their metabolism and then
naming them and so we have lots and lots
of viruses each with its own name but
we're never gonna name them all right
there's just too many different kinds I
think that's fair that we will never
name them all
because basically every organism on
earth every larger organism on earth has
viruses and there are even some viruses
that have viruses oh I did not know that
yes it's it seems odd but and it's it's
actually a fairly recent discovery but
there's a class of mega viruses which
were discovered only in the last couple
of decades in in oceans mostly and some
of these mega viruses actually have
parasitic viruses that grow on them how
big does mega qualify as in this case
well there are viruses that are
literally bigger than back
area okay so they have hundreds of genes
if they I guess they have thousands of
genes they're just but they still have
to are parasitic they still have to grow
inside a cell because they can't do the
two things I imagine they can't make
proteins they can't make energy right
but they actually have some genes that
help them make proteins and they may
even have elements of energy production
so it's getting fuzzier and fuzzier that
line between between viruses and all
other organisms so I used to be
comfortable saying viruses were a
separate Kingdom but I'm not so
comfortable with that anymore
well that was also the impression I was
getting in my reading that rather than
fighting over whether or not viruses
countless living organisms maybe the
lesson is that the boundary between
living organisms and nonliving things is
just not so sharp I mean that there's a
biosphere and viruses play an important
role in it but they bounce back and
forth between cellular organisms no I
think there is a very fundamental
difference between living organisms and
non living organisms and Dysart
nonliving matter yeah
and viruses are living matter in the
sense that they can reproduce they can
evolve and and they are part of the DNA
RNA world and that's not true of rocks
and it's not true of water and it's not
true of a lot of other things which are
nonliving right
they can change so evolving is a an
interesting concept to try to think
about but they they don't have
independent existence yeah so they have
the information storage capability and
and
reproduction passing down their
information to subsequent generations
but they don't have the engine all by
themselves right I mean in order to to
take free energy from the outside world
and get going and do things that's where
they take advantage of the cells they
embed themselves in that's right you
know all organisms depend on the Sun yep
as a source of energy and for viruses
they get into the sun's pipeline through
being inside cells plants for instance
sit out there and in nature and soak up
the Rays of the Sun directly and we eat
plants sometimes we animals which have
in fact even plants yeah so let's go in
a little bit more detail about how the
viruses affect the DNA of the cells that
they go into I mean you mentioned it
very very briefly but it's just a
fascinating story in its richness you
know the viruses themselves can have DNA
or RNA but like you say they don't make
proteins they go in there and hijack so
maybe explain that a little bit more
well to make proteins requires something
called a ribosome which is a very
complex little machine that can decode
the genetic code from DNA or RNA
actually from RNA directly and it never
from DNA right and can read that code as
three base segments of the of code that
code for the four different amino acids
being inserted into proteins so proteins
grow linearly and they grow one two
three four five each a different amino
acid sometimes multiple of the same
amino acid and that whole process which
has to be squeezed
accurate is it something that viruses
simply don't have because they don't
have ribosomes yeah and so they had to
find ribosomes but the so they go in
there do they just take advantage of the
ribosome in the cell or my impression is
sometimes they'll change the DNA or
insert themselves into the DNA or take
pieces out of the DNA of the actual cell
they're living in right there sometimes
when viruses actually insert they're
their own DNA into the DNA of the cell
and actually that's how cancer inducing
viruses work because they become part of
the cell's DNA and now every time the
cell divides it carries the virus along
to the next generation yeah so and if
it's inside and let's say a chicken the
chicken will grow a tumor which is a
whole lot of cells each one of which
have these virus specified sequences in
them which cause the synthesis of
specific proteins that now take over the
cell but that's not the only thing they
can do so there are ways that viruses
can go in there and just use the
ribosome by themselves without messing
with the DNA cell yes okay most of the
RNA viruses for instance go into the
cytoplasm of the cell or the nucleus the
two two compartments of the cell and
they just make more of themselves and
part of what they make is messenger RNA
that specifies particular proteins so
those hop on to the existing ribosomes
and often what the virus does is to
interfere with the cell's messenger RNA
so that the cells messenger RNA can't
get on ribosomes that frees up the
ribosomes so the virus can take full
advantage of it this was something that
I worked out actually in my thesis
oh my dears ago is it is necessarily a
hostile takeover or it can be just the
friendly coexistence there are some that
that are friendly coexistence generally
viruses that don't make much of
themselves that is don't make large
numbers of progeny viruses that do make
large numbers of progeny try to
overwhelm the cell and get rid of any
and the cell dies right because the cell
can no longer provide itself with what
it needs I mean you made this wonderful
distinction that it was really
clarifying to me about equilibrium
viruses versus non equilibrium viruses
viruses that have sort of settled into
coexistence with their hosts and viruses
that are kind of new and untamed and can
cause great damage right and it's
basically that if a virus is part of the
ecosystem of an animal take a human the
virus evolves to be not too greedy so
that it doesn't kill off its host and
the animal or human evolved to fight
against the virus to minimize the amount
of virus that can be made and they come
into an equilibrium where the virus gets
enough handle on cells to make some of
itself but it doesn't it doesn't ask for
a whole lot that's if the virus is
completely dedicated to this one species
but if the virus is in other species
then it may when it gets into humans
become voracious or become very meek
because it hasn't evolved with humans
and those are the viruses that cause us
trouble it makes sense that viruses
would if they're parasitic on their
hosts they would evolve to be in some
kind of relationship with them I mean
when we find viruses out there
in the wild is it generally true that
there is basically one or at least a
small number of species that they're
happy being hosted by yes in general in
fact most viruses are pretty well
dedicated to one species and have come
into equilibrium with that species of
animal or plant or whatever and then it
may infect a few others or it may not
but these non-equilibrium things the bad
guys are very often coming to us human
beings for example from other species
that that's a that's a case where you
jump from one to the other exactly and
so HIV is a virus that is native to
monkeys it doesn't cause serious disease
in monkeys but when it jumps to higher
apes like chimpanzees or jumps to humans
then it causes havoc because it has
developed that modus vivendi yeah and
are the viruses ever not just parasitic
but symbiotic do they ever do something
good for their hosts well not much now
it's it that's a sticky question one
thing that viruses do is kill their
hosts and in the case of for instance
the bacteria in the ocean what it does
is to liberate the the internal workings
of the bacteria so the ocean is a rich
soup hmm because viruses are constantly
killing off cells and breaking them open
now is that is it good for the it's it's
good for the oceans but it isn't really
good for the bacteria I don't think so
it's good for the many but not good for
the few I think yeah something like that
good for the ecosystem well no but but
that's very interesting I mean it's
always good for the ecosystem yes
yeah and viruses are a very important
part of the overall ecosystem yeah I
think you know when I when I said that
the boundary between living and
nonliving might be fuzzy I guess what
I'm what I was thinking of was that the
boundary between an individual and the
ecosystem might be fuzzy because of the
kinds of things that viruses do right
like even if we agree that viruses are
part of life with capital L you know
they move from organism to organism they
even if I think I like what he just said
they serve a purpose to biology even if
not to the individual and and that is
the nature of the ecosystem it's a
system with a lot of different moving
parts I mean you mentioned cancer very
briefly I don't want to let that go by
too quickly how like is cancer always
caused by viruses or often or are we
still investigating that well we are
still investigating it but we think that
the bulk of human cancer is not caused
by viruses okay and although people are
still hunting around seeing if there is
things that we've missed but the common
cancers lung cancer breast cancer
prostate cancer whatever there's really
no evidence for a virus involvement now
in head neck cancer there is a virus
involvement in cervical cancer there is
and in animals there are many more cases
of virus induced cancer so most viruses
as cancers actually studied in animals
is cancer even a coherent category I
mean it's it's some failure in the
reproduction of individual cells but are
there enough commonalities between
different kinds of cancer that it's a
sensible way of thinking or is a viral
cancer very different from a non viral
one well if we go back in history of
little ways we didn't know that viruses
caused cancer and we thought that cancer
was
a disease that was internal to an
organism in some way and when the first
viruses as cancers were discovered
people who were sensitive enough to
numbers realized that viruses were so
small that the only thing they could be
causing cancer with his genes huh and so
we began to study cancers from the point
of view of what genes the viruses had
and we found cancer inducing genes and
then there was the amazing discovery of
Varmus and Bishop that the cancer
inducing genes and viruses actually were
mutated cellular genes so it brought
everything back that brought the cycle
back and we realized that cancer is
induced by genes some are carried by
viruses some are endogenous to the
organism so we get mutations of genes
that cause lung cancer or that cause
breast cancer and no virus is involved
but in other species breast cancer is
caused by viruses and it's even the same
kinds of genes that are involved it's
that the viruses have picked up these
genes and aren't carrying them along
with them that's the history of modern
day cancer research I've just sort of
done it all in one yeah no that that was
great that was extremely clarifying I
mean so is it safe to say cancer is some
kind of genetic failure and viruses are
one way to induce that yes good I don't
know about failure again from our point
of view it's a yeah I think I'm gonna
keep calling it a failure right I know
what do you mean it's a something change
but so I wanna get back there's just too
many interesting things to talk about
here but I don't think that I've quite
wrapped
brain around the ways in which the virus
and the DNA of the host cell interact
because I know that you know your big
discovery for which he won the Nobel
Prize was a little footnote or a little
emendation to the famous central dogma
of biology and maybe you could explain
how that works right so the the central
dogma which was enunciated by Francis
Crick in the 1960s maybe late 50s was
that DNA is the repository of genetic
information for higher cells for us and
our brethren that the way DNA controls
the cell how the influence the
information flows is first by copying
the DNA into RNA and then the RNA
working with ribosomes synthesizing
specific sets of proteins and from the
proteins all of life all of the variety
of life all of the variety of cells
flows and so in in the simplest form of
a dictum DNA makers makes RNA makes
protein right and that was the central
dogma and Crick says I never meant to
say that it couldn't go back the other
way from RNA to DNA what I did but what
I said very strongly was it couldn't
flow from protein back to RNA so what
Howard Temin and I showed in 1970 was
that information could flow backwards
from RNA to DNA and many people said we
violated the central dogma
we showed the central dogma was wrong
but if you believe Francis Crick and I
believe Francis
he had already taken that into account
so I guess I have two questions one is
why is he so sure was he so sure that
you couldn't go from proteins to RNA is
there's some structural barrier there
yes there's an enormous structural
barrier because it's it's literally a
code in RNA that gets transferred into
the structure of protein mm-hmm so to go
back into the code would take a very
complicated machine you just you can't
just go backwards in the proteins of the
aesthetic machinery got it
he also Crick also postulated and and
not long after it was shown that there
had to be an adapter that would adapt
the code to the reality of proteins and
so he understood that there was a lot of
complex machinery that wasn't going to
just reverse itself it's like saying if
you want to take the plans for a house
and make a house out of it going back
from the house and why wouldn't be so
difficult that was a bad example this
there must be a better way example I was
going to use because we just had Scott
Aaronson on the podcast who is a
computer complexity theorist it's easy
to multiply two numbers to get a big
number it's hard to factor a big number
back into its two factors well all right
that's that's actually a good way of
looking at it but that that kind of
argument yeah it doesn't seem to have an
analogue for going from RNA to DNA look
I mean I'm I know very little about this
but my feeling is that RNA is kind of
like just a looser more fragile version
of DNA but it's structurally very
similar that's exactly true the
difference between RNA and DNA is a
couple of chemical bonds and people have
long hypothesized that RNA came first
and was exactly because it's a little
bit
less a little bit less rigid maybe it
was easier to make the first time and
then RNAi led both to proteins and DNA
and modern life are you a fan of that or
in a world
kind of theory I am a fan of the RNA
world theory I think it's very likely
that RNA came first but it's not so much
because it's easier to make RNA than DNA
it isn't it's because RNA isn't a rigid
rod DNA is a this double helix that
winds around itself and forms a long rod
RNA is generally just one strand and so
it it's Wiggly ER and it can do more
yeah okay so actually today DNA looks
like a dull molecule and RNA looks much
more interesting does many more things
and you can it's easier to imagine that
the world had only RNA then that the
world had world had only DNA DNA is a
good place to secure information
securely as it were to store it securely
but RNA is just more active and vibrant
and out there in the world doing things
while at the same time it can also store
information just like DNA kit right
there are double strand DNA viruses
sorry double strand RNA viruses in which
RNA acts exactly like DNA and I mean
maybe I didn't let you finish or we got
distracted from exactly how the central
dogma got amended in a way that would
not offend Francis Crick I mean how is
it that viruses figure out how to go
right from RNA to DNA well we don't know
in an evolutionary sense how that came
about but what we do know is that
there's a class of RNA viruses that
carry with them in their in the virus
particle
an enzyme that can copy RNA into DNA and
that's what I showed and Howard Temin
showed at the same time and for which we
won the Nobel Prize was that the virus
actually had the enzyme in it and it's a
virus specified enzyme so it's picked up
in the previous replication cycle of the
virus and it copies the RNA into DNA as
the first thing it does when it gets
inside a cell and then that DNA goes
into the nucleus which is where we keep
DNA in ourselves and it breaks open
randomly more or less the structure of
the DNA and it literally inserts itself
and end into the cell's DNA and now the
cell inevitably for the rest of its life
has this new genetic information in it
and it's insidious I mean it sounds a
little scary to think that's going on in
our bodies you know that that does sound
bad no these little guys are messing
with our DNA
they're messing matter DNA and we've
been doing it for a long time so
something like 50% of our DNA originated
as viruses carrying around in ourselves
all sorts of interesting little pieces
of DNA that have origins totally outside
of ourselves yeah like that so it's part
of evolution right like I think that
there's a sort of high school version of
evolution where you you know the the
cells break in two and then there's
sexual reproduction occasionally there's
a mutation but the story of viruses
really makes me think that it's much
more open than that right like the the
DNA strands that mom and dad give us are
not quite as sacrosanct as I was led to
believe in my high school biology class
that's right
and we
we call this DNA parasitic DNA because
it's taking advantage of the properties
of DNA in order to propagate an organism
or a piece of an organism which is a
virus it's hard to uh well I mean I
should say it the other way around
it's very tempting to anthropomorphize
these tiny little things I mean Richard
Dawkins famously wrote The Selfish Gene
and a lecture if you if you think that's
a good metaphor but it it certainly does
there is a temptation to think that
there's this you know competition /
cooperation but a constant jostling
inside our genomes between our genes and
the viruses that want to tag along yes
there is all of that and and it plays
out over evolutionary time so there are
things in our genome that actually found
their way into our genome in monkeys or
in actually earlier organisms and have
been carried along ever since then
during the the millions of years of
evolution because it takes a very very
long time to get rid of something once
it's in your genome but we still we draw
these pictures right of you know the
family trees of different species and
families and Genesis and so forth and
and that kind of picture is very
compelling but it hides the idea that
you know there are viruses or other
things I don't know tell me if whoa this
only viruses or there are other things
that kind of insert DNA that did not
come from our ancestors at all no I
think only viruses do that but yes we
have ignored a source of genetic
information which doesn't follow the
usual rules it comes in as an infectious
source and it
is very important does this count as
what's called horizontal gene transfer
yes it is horizontal gene transfer but
what we generally mean when we say
horizontal gene transfer is that among
bacteria DNA from one bacterium can go
to another bacterium and be inserted and
that's something that really doesn't
happen as far as we know in in humans or
in in higher organisms in multicellular
organisms so we never get little pieces
of rabbit DNA or a little piece okay
Mouse DNA whereas bacteria do where they
get little pieces of DNA from other
bacteria well I guess if some viruses
can insert their DNA into us and that
can even be evolutionarily advantageous
and we can pass it down do we ever
insert bits of our DNA into viruses or
do they ever swipe any from us well yes
they do particularly these mega viruses
swipe lots of DNA from their host
organisms and make make it part of them
most of the viruses that infect us are
pretty small and really don't have room
to bring in new genes hmm so they're
they're pretty stable in terms of their
genetic complement so poliovirus today
looks just like poliovirus did during
earlier parts of the evolutionary tree
so the mega viruses infect other kinds
of organisms I mean how do they survive
they do they they particularly infect
something called Acanthamoeba it's a
kind of amoeba that is plentiful in the
ocean I think it's still a question
although maybe things have happened that
I'm not aware of it's still a question
whether these mega viruses also infect
other things yeah even the ocean we're
out of the ocean I don't know the answer
to that even if it's unlikely I kind of
like to imagine the possibility that a
virus could carry a little bit of gene
from a rabbit to a human being I think
that's something biologists should look
into
well you know we're now sequences we're
sequencing the genomes of all sorts of
species and so if that was gonna happen
on any reasonable scale we would see it
okay are we looking oh yeah I mean we're
looking at the DNA and whenever anybody
sequences it they they put it through
computers that check whether the
sequence has ever been seen before okay
all right and so if there were little
bits a rabid DNA in there we would know
it but okay good so if I'm if I'm being
more realistic rather than just hopeful
it's not so much horizontal gene
transfer as just viruses being part of
the ways in which different bits of DNA
or altered or inserted into individual
species and that makes sense that would
that would play a role in evolution yes
and it's also true that the virus the
viruses I mean I should state this as a
statement I should ask us a question is
it viral genetic information more
fragile and therefore does it mutate
more easily than cellular DNA
information no chemically there's no
difference okay viral information
cellular information exactly the same
DNA all the same chemical bonds the
difference is that during the
duplication of the genome in cells we
have devoted a lot of attention to the
precision of that duplication and so the
probability of an era creeping in is
very low and that's the reason that the
number of mutations between me and my
daughter
are very very small through the regions
that that she's inherited from me so
that that process is exquisitely precise
from viruses it's not so precise viruses
first of all treasure speed rather than
accuracy and so they don't want to spend
all the time checking whether every bond
is correct they're willing to accept
some genetic change in fact they may
want some genetic change because they
want to molt they want to mutate and be
able to adapt to new circumstances
through mutation so viruses have set the
bar for precision much lower then we do
then higher cells - yeah okay that man
and that difference is something like
five orders of magnitude six orders of
magnitude oh well I've gotten exactly so
yeah okay that does make sense
III just want to I'm not quite sure we
completely finished this wonderful story
you're telling about the reversal of the
central dogma so the at the end of the
day we have reverse transcription is
that the the label for it yes and it is
retroviruses are the viruses that do it
is that I getting that correct right
right they were named because they
reverse the flow of information and is
an HIV is a retrovirus it is okay and so
when we're when we're moving from
admiring the ingenuity of these little
guys to fighting against them is it an
entirely different game if we want to
sort of battle against retroviruses
versus I don't know pro viruses well I'm
not quite sure what the opposite of a
retrovirus is it's it's all other
viruses okay
and yes we do fight against them in
different ways
and in particular the reverse
transcriptase the enzyme that copies RNA
to DNA is a target for drugs and very
early on when when after HIV was
discovered we had on the shelf drugs
pharmaceutical companies had on the
shelf drugs that could selectively
attack reverse transcriptase and that
was the reason that we had drugs to
fight AIDS within about what five years
of the discovery because there were on
the Shelf these of drugs that
selectively it turned out inhibited this
this polymerase and then we made many
more of them because that one was so
successful but it wasn't enough and it's
been a huge successful story of chemical
synthesis of inhibitors of reverse
transcriptase and some other proteins of
the virus that's enabled us to control
HIV and to control AIDS and maybe let's
be good now to be clear for the non
experts there are different ways of
fighting against these viruses so
there's you know the drug treatments
that you're talking about but there's
also vaccines which are different things
different beasts that's right
so the vaccines are a way of stimulating
our immune system so that it will fight
against a virus and that's a very
different process than chemically
interfering with the growth of a virus
as you as you were saying so vaccines
are a totally different beast yeah right
the drugs that you mentioned are
literally just chemicals that go in
there and get in the way is that correct
right
but the vaccines are much subtler right
so what we do is is to make something
that looks to the immune system
like a virus but doesn't cause disease
mhm and then we give that to people and
people react to it by making antibodies
against the virus because the immune
system thinks it seen a virus and then
if we get a real virus infection the
system is all set up and ready to go and
it reacts much faster than if it hadn't
seen the surrogate virus the the the
vaccine and it reacts so fast that
generally we don't even know that a
virus has entered our bodies yeah and it
gets rid of them and then wears fine it
what is the trick in designing such a
vaccine is it making sure that the right
antibodies are created well yes but we
were making vaccines before we knew
about antibodies so Jenner made the
first vaccines are understood the first
vaccines and that was cow pox injected
into humans so that a human would think
they'd seen smallpox but in fact they'd
seen something much less dangerous than
smallpox but the immune system now was
all prepared to fight off smallpox and
that was very effective I guess what I'm
getting at is is our immune system
always clever enough to fight if it's
been prepared or do we have to sort of
prepare it in different ways you know
are we teaching the immune system what
antibody to make or are we just yes
burying it to do something that it would
have done by itself given enough time
well it would have done it on by itself
give it enough time that's true
but during that time you could be
god-awful sick yeah and I died and so
time is of the essence but so I guess
what a
not quite understanding is is our immune
system more clever than we are in the
sense that it knows how to make an
antibody that would fight this
particular virus well your immune system
is part of us I can't be smarter than we
are smarter than our four brains but the
immune system reacts to any foreign
protein by making antibodies that will
bind to it and that foreign protein may
be a virus or it may be something else
hmm and if the immune system is evolved
as a very general way of recognizing
foreign proteins sequence and if it sees
foreign protein sequence it reacts to it
so it's a very general capability when
we're trying for example to get a virus
for the vaccine for the corona virus
right I mean what what is the
intellectual challenge there what what
are the puzzles that we have to solve to
make that happen
so in principle always should have to do
is to make a preparation of the corona
virus in activate its ability to do to
multiply which we can do chemically and
then inject that and the protein should
act as what we call an immunogen
to stimulate the immune system to make
antibodies and some vaccines are as
simple as that
they're just killed virus the Salk
vaccine famously was killed polio virus
but that doesn't always work sometimes
in the process of killing the virus you
also kill the proteins ability to
stimulate immunity that immune response
lots of things can go wrong in the way
along the way so the Chinese actually
have made a vaccine that way and they're
trying to prove that that vaccine
will actually protect people and will
see it they've showed that it would
protect monkeys but you can also just
take the spike from the surface of the
virus which is a protein mm-hmm and use
that and that's much simpler so you can
make that totally synthetically it's
cheaper to make you control the
manufacture better and so that's
something that many companies and labs
are focusing on right now as a way of
inducing antibodies and we'll see if it
works but the problem is it doesn't
always work we've got lots of history of
failed attempts to do this with other
viruses and more insidiously sometimes
it makes the infection worse rather than
better
it actually helps the virus get into
cells yeah okay and so you don't want
that so you've got to be sure that the
vaccine doesn't do that and that's part
of proving that your vaccine is safe but
yeah you mean correct me if I'm wrong we
still don't have a vaccine for something
like HIV right or the common cold for
that matter there's no guarantee we just
sort of solved this problem on a short
timescale yes but the reasons that we
don't have a vaccine against HIV are
idiosyncratic to HIV okay for reasons
that I'm not gonna try to explain okay
but it is it's it's a fascinating story
about how HIV has evolved to avoid the
immune system and so when we're trying
to make a vaccine we're trying to do
something which never happens as
naturally and we're still trying to make
that happen
the common cold is a different story so
the common cold is more than one kind of
virus there are viruses from different
species of viruses that all cause
there's more or less the same symptoms
which is what we call a common cold many
of them are of a class of viruses called
rhinoviruses Rhino being for the nose
and they all cause sniffles and coughs
and whatever but there are literally
hundreds of them just in humans there
are corona viruses that cause a common
cold
there are add no viruses that cause the
common cold so there are DNA viruses
there are RNA viruses so the common cold
is not something that we can make a
vaccine against because it's so has so
much variety okay that actually makes
sense but so therefore you're saying
that maybe I should not be quite so
pessimistic about corona virus the
corona virus their current work
currently the novel one that we're
currently fighting against are you
optimistic that we will get a vaccine at
some point I am optimistic now that
doesn't mean we're gonna get a vaccine
it only means that I'm optimistic yeah
and I'm sort of an optimist but it looks
to me like this is a pretty ordinary
virus and against most ordinary viruses
we have been able to make vaccines so we
have vaccines against measles mumps
chickenpox never mind
things like smallpox and polio and so
I'm reasonably confident that there will
find a way to make a vaccine within the
next couple of years okay and what I
mean what do we do if let's say it takes
two years or is it there are there
prospects for treatments that will let
us go back to something like normal in
the meantime or are we going to have to
maintain quasi lockdown indefinitely
until the vaccine comes along I don't
see us making a chemical inhibitor a
drug against Cova 19 in any less than a
couple of years so it's it's the same
sort of problem
we could be lucky and people are trying
very hard to be lucky and to find a drug
which we already know is safe and you we
use for something but also will inhibit
the coronavirus right and we we hope
that that something exists but there's
no actual reason why it should I mean
remember viruses have their own
evolutionary history and so their
proteins don't look anything like our
ordinary proteins the proteins of our
body yeah that makes them terrific
targets for the immune system because
they are so different but it makes them
very unlikely to do the same things as
our cells do and so we won't likely have
made drugs against them so yeah I mean
I'm in favor of being lucky but I think
it's also important to at least
conceptualize the pessimists pessimistic
scenario and so what I hear you saying
is it's at least something we should be
prepared for the idea that you know we
don't get any medicine for this for the
next two years and we have to be we have
to combat it in more primitive I guess
ways so let me get on my high horse for
a minute please that's why we're here we
ought to have in our armamentarium drugs
that will inhibit the growth of
coronaviruses all around viruses are
related to each other they all do
basically the same set of things I would
think that the pharmaceutical industry
given enough time and and money could
make drugs against coronavirus and they
wouldn't have to know which coronavirus
it was in order to have inhibitory
molecules but we never spent any time
trying to do that we know
her gave the natural world credit for
what it could produce that would cause a
human pandemic and we should do that and
we should dedicate ourselves now even
though it's late for this for kovat 19
for Cova 20 and 21 22 it's not too late
and we should be now dedicating
ourselves to never be caught like this
again dare I ask
are we dedicating ourselves to that not
that I've seen yeah okay
and as we depend on as long as we depend
on the profit motive right we're not
going to because profit motive doesn't
know which one is worth making yeah okay
okay but we do have research labs
government research labs and
universities that are not completely
profitable that motive driven right
right so there's some problem we have to
find a way to win too we have to find a
way to fund them to incentivize them to
make it you know we've got to have put
up prizes whatever it takes
yep okay that's good and we can act and
it's not just coronaviruses
the same thing is true for a whole range
of other viruses well this is but one of
the questions I wanted to sort of start
winding up with what is the future of
pandemics look like to you I mean is
this just the shape of things to come or
is this a weird outlier I mean in some
sense the fatality rate is around 1% and
you know it's asymptomatic for a couple
of weeks but if there's a virus that is
asymptomatic for a month and has a
fatality rate of 50% then we are in
trouble right right I think most people
feel epidemiologists feel that this is
not an outlier that we should be having
we should have expected this we were
given warning with SARS and MERS mm-hmm
the corona virus has had the ability to
appear in new forms that we
we're not aware of we're out there in
the world we should go in and and
characterize every virus in a bat
because bats seem to be a very effective
reservoir for viruses that can get into
humans but it's not just bats the whole
natural world has viruses that we have
to worry about and so we ought to be
cataloguing them we ought to be doling
out to individual companies the
responsibility to make sure that we can
inhibit them we should take all this
seriously now will we
I don't know I don't know because they
it's been this has been known for years
yeah this is public health and the
history of public health is that when
something stops being a an imminent
problem that we lose our focus on it and
we start using our resources for other
things and this ought to be the lesson
of lessons that we can't do that we have
to keep our eye on the ball and the ball
is that whole world of potential viruses
right I I will take this as on the
optimistic side of the ledger because as
many as our public health failures have
been what your what you're saying is
realistic we could do it it's just up to
us it's not like there's an insuperable
scientific problem here it's just a
matter of willpower right right well and
probably but willpower in money
political will yeah that that's right
and probably for dramatic tension
reasons we should end there but I'm not
gonna let you go yet cuz cuz I have you
here I'm gonna give you two lightning
round questions okay one is one is uh
you've been even active at least
speaking out on the idea of gene editing
and human gene editing this is you know
you haven't talked about it during this
caste but it's obviously a big deal for
science biology humanity right now how
should the people out there be thinking
about the prospects and the dangers of
gene-editing in your view I think if
we're going to use the strengths that
gene-editing gives us to modify human
heredity the place where it seems to me
it's all good and no bad is with certain
kinds of diseases that are in our genome
and that are inherited of families and
that if we could get into those families
into their genes and modify them so that
they don't pass hunting's these disease
they don't pass sickle-cell anemia they
don't pass the many other thousands
literally of diseases that we now pass
around in among humans that that would
be a good thing for the human race right
now there are some arguments about it
and I've I've heard them but I'm gonna
ignore them at least for this
conversation
the problem is that if we do that do we
open a Pandora's box and provide the
opportunity to not change genes that are
bad but to change genes that are
cosmetically less than exactly what we
would want mm-hmm so some people would
like to have children who are very
intelligent I don't know what very
intelligent means I don't know how you
measure it and there are a whole lot of
problems with it but if we knew that it
was attached to specific genes you could
say I want to get that gene into my
inheritance I want my children to have
it or a gene for for height or a gene
for
now there are some things that are at
the borderline for instance obesity is
something which we can control but which
also has a genetic component and and
other things so it's I know it's not
simple no to make that distinction but
let's say it were simple to make the
distinction then we'd have to say can we
control what this technology is used for
so it's used for the right things or not
the wrong things that's a huge challenge
to the modern world because we don't
have the international law the
international treaties so that everybody
in the world will behave in a common way
and that means that if you can't get it
done in the United States you might be
able to get it done somewhere else and
so we are now wrestling with these
issues the issues of where that where
the lines to be drawn what do we want to
allow what don't we want to allow how
are we gonna make common cause across
the world and I realized that this was
going to happen about six or eight years
ago when the first intimations of of
this technology became known and I said
we had to prepare the world to think for
think about these problems and so I
helped organize now two meetings one in
Washington one in Hong Kong that brought
together people from around the world to
begin to think about this I didn't think
that we were going to generate answers
and we didn't but I think we did
generate consciousness we did generate
concern and there will be another such
meeting in a year or two as soon as we
get up meeting again
so far there has been only one it seems
to do this in humans it was a sort of
badly designed attempt by a Chinese
scientist who has been appropriately
stripped of his academic positions in
China right and I hope we keep talking
and we don't see any more attempts to to
put it into practice but I feel that
that it is a technology which can
benefit our species and that we ought to
find a way to get the good and to
control the use of it in in ways that
are less appropriate good that's that's
very useful and I mean I can follow up
obviously but I'm but your your time is
valuable and I will ask you one more
lightning round question I was very
slightly surprised when I read an
interview with you from a few years ago
it contained the following quote from
you the most interesting outstanding
biological question is the origin of
consciousness I'm not going to argue
with that but that seems interesting
coming from a virologist how do you
still believe that is true I do still
believe that's true and we haven't made
much of a dent in it although we made a
little dent in it but why it comes from
a viral gist is because I have another
side to my life which is that I love
institutions I honor what institutions
do and I have been willing to give over
some of my time and energy to running
institutions and so I was president of
the Rockefeller University I was
president of Cal Tech and I have been
involved in a whole variety of things
that relate to the infrastructure of
science rather than
the doing of experimental science and
that means that I have had an
opportunity to look at the widest range
of science and to think about what are
the real challenges in science and what
does it take to build institutions that
can meet those challenges and I came to
the conclusion that neuroscience was the
future and that we have in spite of
working on neuroscience problems for
many generations now we still have a
long way to go to understand how the
brain works and how it controls our
behavior and that within that the most
enigmatic piece of it is consciousness
how do we I mean I've got consciousness
of the room in front of me of machines
in front of me I can tell you all about
it but how do I do it
how do I make the images out of biology
out of neurons that seems like such a
jump I mean the jump from DNA to protein
was an amazing one to jump from neurons
to consciousness is I think orders of
magnitude more challenging to think
about I think that's a great place to
end David Baltimore thanks so much for
being on the landscape podcast my
pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]